Let me,
let me sort of try to frame this a different way.
Um,
alcohol reduces blood pressure.
Okay.
Alcohol in,
you know,
generally tends to reduce cardiovascular events for people.
Um,
and during prohibition you could actually get a doctor's note for alcohol as a
medicine,
but alcohol is not a medicine.
Okay.
It's a recreational intoxicant.
It has some positive biological qualities and some negative biological
qualities.
And you know,
there was an argument I think you intend to 20 years ago.
Should we recommend that people drink moderately one to two drinks a day.
And I think for the most part,
uh,
the medical profession has calmed down on the side of saying,
let's not do that.
There's too many noncardiac uh,
negative side effects with alcohol.
Just on that note though,
Alex in Canada right now,
I know the safe alcohol drinking guidelines or 14 drinks week nine drinks a week
for,
for women say,
you know,
basically to sue a day for men,
one for women.
So you're saying,
okay,
like there's,
we don't see huge negative consequences at that level.
Okay.
That's,
that's fine.
That's a totally reasonable way to think about alcohol.
But what we're not saying to people is this is a medicine.
And I think that's where the confusion around really around high THC,
cannabis lies.
And I,
and again,
I don't mean to say that your friend's child is not benefiting.
I if you say,
uh,
he or she's benefiting.
I believe you.
What I'm saying is that that's not good enough for science.
We need randomized controlled trials.
And when those trials have been done and a lot of them have been done,
Joe,
a lot of them have been done.
They've almost unequivocally shown that cannabis doesn't work as a medicine,
the only actual place where beyond these sort of very limited conditions like
chemotherapy associated nausea,
which obviously is terrible for people who have it,
but isn't,
isn't that common?
Fortunately,
um,
cannabis has been shown to work as a pain reliever,
right?
Probably for the same reasons that alcohol works as a pain reliever sort of
dulls your awareness of your pain.
But even in that study or in those,
even in those studies,
they're mostly done against placebo,
not against opioids or against and ceds like Ibuprofen.
And there was a very big study for cannabis use in chronic pain over a multi
year period,
uh,
in Australia that came out last year that showed that people who used cannabis
had a,
uh,
had more pain and use more opiates at the end of four years,
then people who didn't.
So the,
so I,
I,
we're almost arguing about what medicine is.
Yeah.
That study though had a lot of flaws in it.
And the other thing is that you need to look at someone who is already using
cannabis versus someone who is just using opioids.
So if someone is just using opioids and they want to come off cannabis,
um,
you know,
there's mole come off opiates,
sorry,
come off of opiates with cannabis use.
Multiple studies have shown that that that can be,
uh,
effective.
And that's not what was done in the Australian study that you're referring to.
It's a more approach.
Right.
And,
and also too,
you know,
they,
they didn't have access to medical marijuana during that whole,
during that whole time.
Right.
So those are all self reported and they were getting it from,
you know,
recreational sources.
They weren't getting it from.
That's a big,
that's a big distinction though Alex.
Like they weren't getting it from a doctor who prescribed it.
Two of them.
They were,
they were,
this is a self report it study and people were getting cannabis that you know,
they didn't really know what they were getting.
It wasn't a,
they weren't given any information from a doctor and that's why it's a medicine
Alex,
because you can tell someone,
you can tell a patient to take a certain amount of CBD every single day and when
you take a certain amount every single day,
it can reduce your symptoms and sometimes you need to increase that and
sometimes you need to decrease that.
We do that with all medicines.
Should be really clear about the distinction though,
between CBD and marijuana.
I mean we're really talking about the psychoactive version of it,
right?
This is where,
where you're saying it's negative,
you're not,
you're not really arguing that
dr hardest talking about,
he's talking about using this as a medicine.
Certainly using the CVD.
He's titrating his patients,
he's monitoring,
he's not writing them an authorization and st come back in a year when it,
when it's up,
he's,
he's being a physician and you know,
and I think to the extent that marijuana is medicine,
we want people like him.
So you are admitted to medicine?
No,
no,
no.
I don't admit that,
but he just said that.
I don't think I just said that
cause I think I said to the extent,
I'm trying to stop doing that.
Um,
uh,
but you know,
I think you said something else that was really interesting to me.
And this came up in the book too.
So you're a clinician,
you see sick people and you know,
it's funny,
my wife's a doctor too.
She's a psychiatrist.
That's how I sort of got hidden this.
But my wife is a forensic psychiatrist less than a clinician these days.
Her job is to evaluate people,
not so much to treat people.
Your job is to treat people.
You see sick people.
You want to help them feel better and you don't want to tell them,
there's nothing I can do for you.
There's nothing there.
There's no hope for your pain.
There's no hope for your PTSD.
You want to help them.
And I totally get that.
But if you're an epidemiologist or a researcher who's,
who's trying to guide the,
you know,
the views and the medical practice of hundreds of thousands of doctors,
that's not good enough.
So you need to step back.
And I think,
I think you know this,
this epidemiologist in in Britain who I talked to,
he said to me,
he said,
you know,
I try not to draw conclusions because so often when I try to draw them,
I'm wrong.
Yeah.
And we need to be careful about that.
Right.
And Alex,
you know,
one thing that was mentioned in your book,
um,
you know,
it was that,
you often,
you often cite at the national academies of Science and Engineering,
right?
But,
you know,
Ziva Cooper,
she's a member of that committee.
I mean,
she put out on our Twitter,
you can go to it.
It's from January 9th of 2019 she says in response in the recent year times
editorial on cannabis and as a committee,
which can,
which by the way that,
let me finish,
let me finish people context of where it came from.
Right.
But this is someone you site.
Yep.
No,
I didn't cite her.
I cited you cited that the report and she's a member of that,
of that.
Okay.
So she said in response to the recent New York Times editorial on canvas and as
a committee member on NASA,
which is that committee and can adenoids report,
we did not conclude that cannabis causes schizophrenia.
Then the drug alliance policy also said the report did not reach that
conclusion.
So you know,
those are pretty too authoritative,
uh,
you know,
sources that they're saying that,
in your book you didn't cite the research properly.
Right.
And then also they're saying that you left a lot out,
right?
They said that they have found an association between marijuana use and improved
cognitive outcomes in individuals with psychotic disorders that straight from
the same report.
And you know,
you failed to mention that.
Right?
So I think that,
you know,
when we're writing books or when we're giving out information,
you want to do it from a balanced approach and you don't want to just select,
you know,
the small amount of,
of material that's just going to support your study.
You know,
we want to be truthful here.
Joe's show is all had been very,
very truthful.
I mean,
Joe said,
right,
right at the beginning,
he doesn't think that,
uh,
that,
that cannabis is perfect for everyone and I don't think that either.
And in Canada,
you know,
we have really strict guidelines to follow.
Um,
you know,
basically no one prescribes to seed anyone under the age of,
uh,
of 25 and,
you know,
all the conferences and stuff that I go to,
we don't really have too many discussions about that.
Like the doctors don't really have many,
you know,
much of a backlash about that.
Um,
so why,
why is the distinction the age of 25 whether they decide that age?
So 25,
basically is when your brain is fully developed.
And when you do look at the studies that do show you an association between,
between cannabis and psychosis,
it's almost all in adolescence.
You know,
I think that Alex only has one study,
um,
and,
and his and his book that shows an extremely weak correlation between,
um,
an adult using cannabis and then developing any type of mental illness later.
So,
you know,
25,
um,
is,
is a,
is a good age,
but it's definitely a kind of a conservative ish,
ish age.
But,
you know,
it's something that we fall and I think that,
we've done well with that in Canada.
So Alex,
why did you leave those conclusions?
I need to push back here.
Okay.
Um,
so the National Academy of Medicine Report,
uh,
was,
drawn up by committee of 16 researchers.
Uh,
Ziva Cooper is the one who's publicly said the report said this.
but I think that we should have,
uh,
emphasize that it also said this.
Okay.
What I,
what I wrote in that New York Times op Ed.
Uh,
what I wrote in the book is the plain language of the report and the plain
language is this cannabis use is associated with a risk of developing
schizophrenia and other psychosis.
The higher the use,
the greater the risk.
I may have a word or two wrong in that cause I'm doing it from memory,
but that's what it said.
And by the way,
the committee was very clear.
They separated a depression.
They said there we don't see as nearly as high risk for depression and
psychosis.
Uh,
even though by the way today,
just today,
uh,
Gemma Psychiatry,
the Journal of the American Medical Association Psychiatry,
uh,
put out a Meta analysis showing that cannabis is associated with depression and
suicidal thinking,
uh,
and actually suicide attempts at a three and a half to one rate.
This,
this literally was released today.
Um,
but to,
but to go back,
Ziva is one of 16 members of that committee.
So if you're going to talk,
you're going to say that I misquoted the report,
which I did,
and I quoted entirely accurately.
You need to say,
well,
why aren't the other 15 members of that committee saying that I misquoted.
Why is one person who works for the cannabis research initiative at Ucla,
which takes money from cannabis investors and users?
She's the one who said that I misquoted it.
Maybe she,
maybe we should ask why the other members of the committee are not speaking out
against my book.
Well,
I think that she was just one of the 16 members that that came out.
But you know,
you can't really expect all the other members to,
to potentially,
you know,
come out with that.
It's not,
why not?
Well,
some people did something wrong if I misquoted them.
Well some people will and some people won't.
You know,
some people have,
you know,
the personality.
Some people have the platform like,
you know what,
Ziva has a bunch of followers on our Twitter.
People know who she is.
You know,
a lot of people who do research actually are not into social media at all.
Like I don't think you were at all before you,
you had your book.
Where are you?
Right.
Okay.
So,
so you weren't into social media at all.
you know,
I don't think that most people on that committee are,
are into social media.
You know,
Ziva just,
just happens to be,
and I even spoke to Ziva,
uh,
on the phone about this and you know,
and she said that,
yeah,
you know,
I don't,
uh,
that she agrees with everything that was in the report,
but she doesn't agree with your conclusions.
And to go back to what's our quoted from the report,
but you're only quoting there,
but you're only quoting the parts that,
that site or sorry that back,
your,
uh,
your opinions,
you're not quoting the entire part like you left.
Like why did you leave out the part that said they have found an association
between marijuana use and improve cognitive outcomes and individuals with
psychotic disorders.
Right.
So you're leaving out that person.
Why did you leave that by that you leave out that part
if you can find me a psychiatrist who thinks that it's a good idea for somebody
with an active psychotic disorder to that part.
Why did you leave out that part?
Well,
my book presents,
it makes a case,
right?
It makes a case that this is a big issue that we have not heard about at all and
the reasons that we haven't heard about it have a lot to do with the advocacy
community and the way they've presented this data for 25 years.
I a book that is trying to break through a lot of noise,
so but still like to get a balanced approach.
Did you decide that you were only going to say you're only going to write about
things that confirm your belief that you held when you were writing this and
what you were trying to push in the title of the book and then in the conclusion
of the book?
I think that's a really great question.
I say in the introduction to the book,
this book is not balanced.
There's not a lot of evidence in there.
If you want a fair,
if you want to read about how indican sativa strains are different and you know,
you're not going to read that in this book,
this and,
but I will also,
I also want to say this,
I didn't come at this and I say this in the introduction in the book too,
as an anti cannabis crusader.
In fact,
when my wife said to me,
as she said to me over and over again in 2014 and 15 and 16,
these are the cases that I'm seeing.
These are the terrible things that people are doing after cannabis use.
I sort of said to her,
first of all,
why do I always have to hear about this at the dinner table?
But more importantly,
um,
you know,
why?
Why is it that maybe these people were using other drugs?
Maybe,
maybe you're seeing a slice of the population that that's not representative.
Why is it that I should believe this?
This sounds like reefer madness to me.
And,
you know,
ultimately my wife,
who's the one who went to,
you know,
she actually,
as I was talking to doctor heart about this,
she grew up in,
uh,
in Newfoundland to,
she went to the Memorial University of Newfoundland Medical School and she went
to Harvard and Columbia for her postgraduate training.
Uh,
you know,
eventually she got tired of me yapping back at her and she said,
why don't you go read the studies yourself?
And it was that,
that led me to read,
to write this book because when I read the studies,
I could not believe the strength of the evidence,
Joe.
But you're still even in saying that you're still seeing positive results that
you're,
you're excluding.
Again,
there's,
there's this one,
there's this one sentence that means not just one sense,
but,
but there are a few sentences about how it may be that cannabis helps people's
positive because it helps,
it helps cognition in people with psychosis.
Maybe,
maybe not.
Wouldn't that qualify as medicine?
Uh,
not if it's,
no,
it wouldn't be approved as medicine.
If it's causing to have other psychotic episodes.
You've got these people have psychotic breaks and improves cognitive function
and people with psychotic breaks.
So,
so wouldn't that be something that you would see some prescribed to snow him?
No.
Again,
you need to think about how the FDA is looking at medicine.
No,
I understand the FDA's position.
Sure.
But I mean looking at it as medicine,
I mean if we could prove this through studies and through some sort of clinical
trials,
if it is improving your Iq two points on a test.
And was that all it is?
I'm not.
I think
I'd have to look at that.
I'm not sure.
But at the same time it's making you literally map.
No,
it's too,
but at the same time it's making you floridly psychotic.
You're not,
that's not medicine.
Well,
it's not necessarily the same time.
One of the things that I read about schizophrenia and was that there's people
who are trying to make a correlation between marijuana use in schizophrenia.
But the problem with that correlation in what I read,
and maybe you could help me on this,
was that it's the exact same number that you find.
The general population is essentially 1% of the general population has
schizophrenia,
which is one out of a hundred people.
And when you have marijuana users,
you see is essentially that same number mirrored.
And so they're saying that a small number of people hold on,
but it wasn't getting in a small number of people.
What they were saying essentially in what I read was that marijuana use was
associated with the onset of schizophrenia.
But they were disputing this in this study because they were saying,
but because then same number is mirrored in the general population.
Again,
correlation does not equal causation.
Right?
Doctor,
I think you got to tell them that's not true.
So tell me truly what that means.
Traditionally,
yes,
we look at the stats.
You'll see that,
you know,
the people who use cannabis versus the people who don't use cannabis have very
similar rates,
but you're getting to the exact rates,
you know.
So in the u s they say that,
uh,
the range if for schizophrenia is between 0.25 to 0.64%.
Globally.
They say it's 0.33 to 0.75%.
So,
you know,
right there,
it's,
you know,
apparently lower in in the u s and the u s is,
is,
has the highest percentage of cannabis consumption in the world.
And the US also has a lot of people that are using high potency THC.
So,
you know,
I think that,
we really need to be,
be careful about throwing out stats like that because you know,
when you do look at the stats that we have,
it shows that even though,
uh,
you know,
that there's a lot of cannabis use in the United States,
schizophrenia rates have remained the same.
So I have to push back really hardly.
This is one of the great myths of legalization.
Okay.
Um,
no one knows what the schizophrenia or psychosis rate in the is in the u s
because a lot of people aren't treated.
Oh,
people aren't treated.
People get different diagnoses at different times.
And we have,
we have bad health care in this country and we have a lot of protections around
mental health.
In fact,
in 2017 the national institutes of mental health suddenly changed its estimate
for the percentage of people with schizophrenia in the US from 1.1% to 0.3% they
did it with no public notice.
And then this researcher said,
hey,
this is a miracle.
They just cured 2 million people with schizophrenia and the,
and then in response to that,
the director of the NIH said,
um,
well we actually don't know how many people have schizophrenia in the United
States.
Nobody knows,
nobody knows if the rate is increasing.
Nobody knows if it's decreasing.
The only countries where they can count noses on this with any accuracy.
Our northern Europe,
because they have good healthcare because I have slightly less protections
around so or individual privacy and mental health privacy.
And so they are able to count cases and in Denmark and Finland,
which are,
which are the two places where they've actually done this research in the last
20 years,
they've shown increasing rates of schizophrenia between about 1995 and about
2010 and that goes side by side with increasing rates of cannabis use in the 90s
so the people who are saying that there's no evidence of population wide
increases in psychosis are just wrong.
That's just possible that there's other facts.
Oh,
absolutely.
Environmental factors is a bunch of other different things that,
let me,
let me sit here on this.
We absolutely don't have the evidence at this point to say that cannabis use in
the u s is causing a population level increase in psychosis and schizophrenia,
which are,
by the way,
those are sort of different illnesses and we can,
we can talk about that too.
So we don't have the evidence to say there's a definite increase.
But what I'm saying is that what you have been told that there is no increase in
schizophrenia or psychosis rates in the u s that's,
we don't know if that's true or not.
We just don't me ask you this,
there has been proven that there's an increase in marijuana use.
Is that correct?
Correct,
absolutely.
How,
when,
when did the increase begin and how,
what,
how,
what percentage increase?
So there was a,
there was an increase in the 90s and increase in use and in potency you sort of
bottomed out around 1991 and then there was sort of a flat bottomed out mean it
hasn't increased since [inaudible] 91 or [inaudible] 50% since 92 so that's a
lot.
That's a lot.
It wouldn't you expect a corresponding increase in schizophrenia if there was
any sort of correlation,
hold on,
let me just,
let me walk you through.
Okay.
It bottomed out in the early nineties increased again,
increased in the 90s flattened out between about 2000 2006 and since then has
been going up again,
especially in let's say the last three,
four years.
And the other thing is that potency in the last 15 years has gone way up.
I don't think anybody would dispute that,
but okay.
Has Schizophrenia,
Ghana.
So what I'm saying to you is we don't know,
there is evidence there is,
there is now evidence on a population level basis in those other countries that
schizophrenia and psychosis has gone up.
And there's for the first time in 2017,
there's data showing that serious mental illness,
which is not the same as psychosis or schizophrenia in the US,
doubled between 2008 and 2017 in the and the in people aged 18 to 25 and those
are the people who are most likely to be using.
So for the first time,
there's actually evidence of what you're talking about,
which is a population wide increase.
Now again,
I'm not going to say,
can I get you to clarify,
it shouldn't say serious mental health.
So serious mental illness.
So this was defined.
Uh,
there's a study called the national survey on drug use and health.
It's done every year,
cover 70,000 people.
Federal government funds it.
It's sort of the best data source we have on all this stuff.
Um,
it showed that,
and they're not counting cases either.
No.
Let me just be as clear as I can on this.
Nobody's counting schizophrenia in cases on a national or even state level basis
in the u s but you say to people,
did you have depression so bad that you couldn't get out of bed?
Did you,
you know,
were you hospitalized this year for a psycho,
for,
for any inpatient psychiatric reason?
And,
and if you look at those numbers in 2008,
3.7%,
I remember it maybe was 3.8% of Americans,
18 to 25 reported,
uh,
at least one symptom.
So they were categorized as having serious mental illness that year in 2017 that
number was 7.5%.
So that's a doubling.
So again,
I am not going to say that proves that the increase in cannabis use has caused
this,
this population something things.
But something bad has happened.
And if you look at kids 12 to 17,
interestingly,
they,
over that time where we didn't have a big increase in cannabis use in general,
teenagers are actually are pretty healthy now.
Although jewel and vaping maybe undoing that and those kids didn't have a
population level increase in serious mental illness.
Can I stop you for a second there because there's other factors.
One of the big one is,
you've all know Herati has a great book,
a 21 lessons for the 21st century.
I read that.
It's great.
So one of the things they talk about is the onset of social media.
Uh,
Jonathan Haidt talked about that as well and uh,
that the onset of social media,
oh,
he's actually more hate.
And then,
uh,
you've all Herati but the,
Jonathan Haidt talks about it with young people.
Yeah,
that's American mind.
Yeah.
I think that social media and the pressures of social media have led an
incredible amount of young people to,
uh,
serious mental distress and,
you know,
serious anxiety,
serious depression and suicide amongst young girls has increased some 50%
according to hate.
Um,
over the period of 2007,
two,
I think 2000 and whenever his book was written.
Uh,
and I think they're directly correlating that to the pressures of social media
and to,
you know,
anonymous online bullying and all these different factors that are affecting
kids.
Yeah.
So I think that that could be considered a far more significant new,
uh,
form of,
of,
of distress to children and young people then even marijuana.
I think it does it twofold because I think that,
you know,
what makes people really depressed maybe more so than,
than anxious,
but definitely both.
Is that when you compare yourself to someone else and yes,
you know,
people,
obviously that we've done that,
you know,
all,
all humans have done that,
you know,
since since history began.
But now everything is online.
You can compare your life to everyone and that people are doing all the time.
And even worse than that,
and you know when we should talk about this too,
is that the income gap is getting,
is getting water.
So it's like people's lives,
not only are they getting,
you know,
better than,
than,
than other people's lives,
but it's what it now it's on,
it's on display so everyone can see it.
Whereas before,
you know,
maybe you wouldn't have seen it because it wasn't on social media,
but now it's on social media.
So you had this huge income gap that just keeps getting bigger and bigger and
bigger.
And then you have people going,
going on social media and they're comparing themselves and you're absolutely
right,
especially in that,
in that age population when people under,
under the age of 30,
you know,
they're,
um,
you know,
they're being bullied online.
Like I see it everyday in my office,
like literally every day people are being bullied online.
And that's something that I never had to deal with,
uh,
growing up.
Um,
and you know,
a lot of kids do have,
do,
have to,
to deal with that.
Just one more note to on,
on the,
uh,
since Colorado has,
has,
has legalized cannabis,
is this important for,
for this,
uh,
this,
this subject in this topic?
Um,
they've actually seen marijuana rates decrease.
So it's important for people to know that,
you know,
just
to study or overall use or I use has gone up.
Teen years is flat overall uses up.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm talking about teen use that,
that,
that's the category that we're talking about under under 30.
Right.
So teen use,
you know,
would,
would classify as part of that category.
So,
you know,
in Colorado we have seen a decrease.
Do you think that's because of the lack of the,
because it's not illegal,
it's not as exciting to them?
Part of it for sure.
You know,
and I mean,
part of it like one worry I had,
you know,
I haven't looked into the statistics yet was you know,
when,
when you're growing up and,
uh,
when you're in high school,
you know,
if you want to be part of the cool crowd,
so to say,
you know,
you usually drink or you smoke pot,
that's,
that's what people do.
Um,
I hope that that doesn't change because pot scene as medicine,
I hope that,
you know,
people don't,
move on to or,
or do something you'll harsher because they don't see pot as as cool anymore.
Right.
That is attached to it because it's legal.
Yeah.
So I got to push back on it please.
So everything you say about social media is down.
You know,
it's sort of intuitively sounds correct.
Right.
The problem is the data doesn't support this at all.
The data shows that teenagers another 12 to 17 those kids are healthier than
they were 10 or 20 or 30 years ago.
They drink less,
they smoke less,
they have sex later.
The fewer abortions they are healthier.
Okay.
And their mental health doesn't seem to have changed that much based on the NSD
ewh data.
Okay.
The data shows a big change in kids 18 to 25 they go to college.
Something goes wrong for a lot of those kids,
at least in the last few years now.
But what do you mean when you're talking about suicide rates?
Suicide rates are there.
The,
especially with young girls who are apparently more effected by social media,
they have gone up significantly since the rise of social media.
That is the big fan of people who are most likely the second more so than
cannabis use.
And then that's a fact.
So,
so you're,
so you're talking about a tiny,
tiny number of people who know.
No,
it's not a tiny number of people.
50% increase of people that commit suicide.
They're young girls that people who commit suicide in the United States are
middle aged white men.
And that's as a fat girl.
But wait a minute,
you're discounting these young girls that are committing suicide to fit your
statistics or to fit your conclusions?
No,
what I'm saying is that's a tiny,
tiny number,
but it's a 50% increase is not a tiny amount.
This is something that we
can look up.
Well,
let's find out what the numbers are.
Right?
Because like when Jonathan Haidt was on the podcast and you discussed it,
I mean he showed this chart and it's an alarming increase directly correlating
with the increase in use of social media.
Sure.
I am,
by the way,
I'm going to let you push back against that.
So it seems to be a factor.
What I'm,
when I'm pushing back against is the idea that kids 12 to 17 generally are less
healthy than they were 10 or 20 years.
If no one's saying they're less healthy,
you just said they're more healthy.
You,
I'm saying they're more healthy,
right?
I'm all,
we're saying that Kid's health has nothing to do with cardiovascular and Phil,
I'm answering mentally healthy.
I mean they're less likely to use drugs that are less likely to have sex with
them,
more likely to commit suicide.
That is a tiny,
tiny number.
What are you talking about?
If it's 50% increase,
that's a huge difference.
We should look up the number if we're gonna.
If we're gonna just Jonathan hates work is like very well respected.
What I'm saying to you is that there's a clear increase in psychological
distress in kids and young adults,
18 to 25 okay.
There's a clear increase and those are the people who are most likely to be
using cannabis and people that are most likely on social media as well,
and that's a stressful period of [inaudible] 17 are usually living at home like
18 to 25 then you've got to go to university,
you got to deal with all these core sees mood.
You can see the,
and I've said it at the beginning of the program that I think the marijuana with
some people is not beneficial and in fact could be negative,
but I don't understand why you're not willing to admit that social media has a
significant and unprecedented impact on young people that we've never seen
before.
I would totally agree with that,
but I don't think that you can say based on the population level data that the
impact is all negative.
It may be,
listen it who's saying that the impact is all negative.
What we're saying is it a 50% increase in suicide with young girls?
Right,
but that's huge.
Let me hear here.
Let me give you an example.
When you were 15 or I was 15 maybe you got really drunk,
right,
and wound up in a bathtub.
Like maybe kids today are less likely to do that because of social media because
they know it's going to be on Instagram forever.
I don't think that's true.
I don't think that's proven.
I don't think there's anything that would point to that.
Well,
what I can tell you is proven is that kids,
today I'm talking about teens,
12 to 17 have less psychological distress by all these measures I'm talking
about.
Their actual behaviors are better or a better or worse.
That's a moral judgment,
but they're healthier than they were 10 or 20 or 30 years ago.
They're less likely to have sex.
They're less when they're 14 which I think most people say is a good thing.
They're less likely to be drinking.
They're less likely to be smoking.
Those are good things.
Well,
less likely to be drinking,
less likely to be smoking,
less likely to have sex does not correlate to positive mental outlook and less
suicide.
Well,
yes,
there's,
I agree there we look,
let's look at the numbers.
But depression and suicide at the very difficult things to measure,
right?
Depression,
well,
suicides,
actually suicides [inaudible] it's a hard number.
Depression is a,
is at this spike located bottom numbers in females,
so,
okay.
I mean this is what I'm saying.
The death rate,
first of all,
this is,
okay.
The death rate for girls age 15 to 19 is four per 100,000 jokes at 40 it's at a
40 year high.
Right.
So I mean you'd be hard put to say that's a huge spike.
It was three per hundred thousand in 1975 and it's a little bit over four in
2015 that's not,
that's one case per 100,000 girls.
Yeah.
I don't know what,
I don't know what the actual facts are.
I'm looking at this right now.
The suicide rates for teens,
15 to 19 years.
This is something that we'd have to study.
Sure.
People have this discussion.
I'm telling you,
giant spike for boys in the 1990s what the fuck is that?
About?
95 one no surprise.
If you put middle aged men on this chart,
you'd have to,
you'd have to blow out the ceiling.
Like people,
the suicide crisis is unfortunately a crisis of age.
Okay.
I would agree with that.
I think we actually talked about that yesterday with Andrew Yang that a suicide
amongst men in their 50s,
and then they start to feel useless.
Yeah.
And especially if they lose their jobs.
Um,
but what Jonathan Haidt is pointing to is a direct correlation between social
media use,
depression and suicide amongst young girls.
Um,
thank you for finding out.
What is it?
This is the article.
It's from his,
uh,
from this suicide rate for teen girls.
The highest it's been in 40 years is social media to blame.
Right.
So,
okay.
Um,
new data prevented a release Thursday by the Atlanta based Centers for Disease
Control and prevention suicide rates amongst 15 to 19 year old girls doubled
between 2007 and 2015 reaching a 40 year high.
I would say that significant.
Again,
I would add,
and it's obviously a terrible thing when anybody commits suicide,
but we're talking about two per 100,000 I understand they actually,
it's,
it's five,
well went from two to four.
Okay.
That means for every 100,000 American girls in 2015 five committed suicide.
That's not a very high number.
But I mean that's also someone who pushed to the extreme of taking their life.
How many girls are experiencing severe depression but don't commit suicide.
That's the real factor because this is what hate directly connects to social
media.
Again,
the 50% increase,
you're talking about a relatively small number because not as many girls commit
suicide as men,
but still this could,
you're talking about,
you were talking about depression,
right?
And you were talking about the significant factors that would lead people to be,
to have poor mental health.
This could be a huge factor in this.
Right,
and I think that too,
it leads people to,
you know,
suicidal ideations and depression and anxiety.
Me Right here,
we're just looking at seaside,
which is the worst possible,
which is very rare amongst girls periods or less common or just yes,
men,
men do commit suicide more than women do.
But you know,
we really have to be careful about that because you know,
again,
suicide is,
is the aim.
That's the worst thing that could possibly happen.
So what about,
you
know,
all,
all the,
uh,
all the things leading up to it,
you know,
are there people who are,
who don't commit suicide but you know,
suffer from terrible depression,
suffer from terrible anxiety,
suffer from terrible insomnia,
you know,
those people are not accounted for in that graph.
I,
I agree.
And when I'm saying is that cannabis use has spiked in the United States in the
last 15 years and teens not withstanding,
we've seen a large degradation in a number of these social outcomes.
And now,
just today we have a Jama Psychiatry paper that looked at a bunch of other
studies that said cannabis use in teenagers is associated with depression,
suicidal ideation,
and suicide attempts in people once they get to 18 to 30.
Okay.
So again,
to last may be a factor.
What's that?
It could possibly be a fat.
Sure,
yes.
But it might,
it might also be that these kids are depressed because of social media and
they're using cannabis or they're depressed because their friends died from
opioid overdoses.
A lot of potentials,
lifestyle,
the fact,
you know,
we are conceding the fact that,
you just said again,
that study was done on adolescents.
You know,
Joe and I have both conceited at multiple times that,
you know,
we do not think,
hi,
cheat.
See Cannabis is good for people in that age category.
But you know,
just to,
just to back up just a little bit again,
you know,
I don't,
like I said earlier that,
you know,
I don't prescribe Cisi generally to anyone under the age of 25 and most of the
doctors in Canada don't.
But I think that we should be prescribing CBD to these kids.
Like a lot of those kids who have a suicidal ideations,
depression,
I mean,
you know,
you could never do a study on it,
but you know,
how many of those kids wouldn't have committed suicide or wouldn't be feeling
this way if they were using CBD because we know Ssri,
selective Serotonin reuptake inhibitors,
you know,
which are the most commonly prescribed a medication for depression and anxiety
even in,
in a,
in adolescence.
Um,
we know that they,
they,
they can't increase a suicidal ideations that's been shown.
I mean,
it's written right on,
right on the package.
So again,
like as a clinician,
you have to treat your patients.
If you're just treating people with something that's not effective or the there
that has horrible side effects,
you're going to look at other alternative treatments.
A lot of people have,
have,
have shown our story,
have had excellent results with CBD in that age category.
You know,
I've had had it done in my practice and lots of other,
you know,
physicians have had done in their practice.
So it's really important that when we're talking about teenagers and we were
talking about that study,
you're talking about high potency THC in adolescence.
That's where Joe and I both can see that,
you know,
THC is not a good medicine.
Well look,
if Gw Pharma or somebody else can,
can do it,
a study with CBD and depression or some other cannabinoids and non intoxicating
Canambra in depression and get it approved for that,
that'd be great.
We need,
we need the treatments for depression and for,
and boy do we need treatments for psychosis that we can get.
Um,
I totally agree with that and I'm really glad to hear you say you don't think
that adolescents should be using high potency or drugs or any hardware,
especially alcohol.
No.
And they,
and they should try to also stay away from the other medications.
I want to push.